migos in the beta we can be out of
cultures yeah we finna put up on I'm
Mike is it the way you guys can play
council music rolling in the background
rain drops in the hot ball [ __ ] on
your [ __ ] yet back back back cooking up
dope in the car [ __ ] my business bad and
Bush back cooking up the way the ocean
oh my [ __ ] are savage ruthless I got
better than hunter roster Wilfred what's
up it knock your [ __ ] ass out
that's not like by my boy look good
smelling good oh yeah alright let's
check out what I'm doing over here to it
my bird Cooper listen my boy might got
the birds in a chop did you do the
trippity hey come on here let me show
you some stuff let's pop pedigree stuff
right here you give him the Fiji water
soon yeah everything honey train put him
in here for like two weeks
nevermind hungry he always come to
always come back less a hawk give him
something and then the hawk in the
Falcon with him oh I know he got so much
probably like his bills and memorabilia
don't just see the history ask for some
[ __ ] take it back put it in my frame and
frame it little never touch me won't
leave for devil who fight you a guy it's
outweighed the heaven team play Monopoly
he represents crimp our attack mode
Venna dog
I can hear all I really feel like you're
a great guy the hell champions are now a
new chant with you Jim you did you're
the first man I see with a tiger and
right now I'm trying to buy me a white
type yeah the white tiger Dan you just
hold him off on okay get rid of him baby
gotta get rid of getting these kids to
school they want to go to university
Milo University how old is he
eight
what was that your plan
you can't put out that's good
yeah the only way sound great you're
welcome keep it up all right we'll sit
that morgue really sure new great to
throw up now but with the future yeah
yeah how's your gas time yeah
three Chevy Cruze appreciate yawns
everybody for Santi for Santi for Santi
who's had such a positive for such a for
such a feeling for searching for
something for such a massaging for such
a percentage because you said sadly for
setting sun set for such a GU gu oh oh